the Centers for Disease Control and
prevention appears to be following the
lead of some 49 states by relaxing
indoor Mass mandates officials say
Friday's revised guidance lifts the need
for most Americans to wear face
coverings inside the change is designed
to help communities live with the virus
as they shift closer to their
pre-pandemic ways by helping counties
adjust regulations based on
hospitalizations and Hospital capacity
not on the number of coveted cases
Michael George is here with the latest
Michael good morning Elaine good morning
some encouraging news here in the last
two weeks covet infections dropped 65
percent across the U.S that's part of
the reason the CDC is saying masks are
no longer needed in much of the country
but the final say on masks is still up
to State and local governments so the
rules may be different depending on
where you live
in New Orleans where Mardi Gras goers
are arriving for next week's festivities
it'll still be masks on indoors plus
proof of vaccination or a recent
negative covid test at bars restaurants
and nightclubs we've been to breakfast
twice dinner and everyone asked for it
with your ID
and I'm fine with that
100 but in Los Angeles where County
officials eased indoor requirements the
reaction Friday from hair stylist
Gabrielle sagona was not surprising I'm
just happy to wear lipstick again I mean
it's really that easy
and she smiles a patchwork of data
plotted by County shows areas with High
cases and few hospital beds in red
yellow and green indicating places where
the strain on the Health Care system is
lower and mass mandates can be rolled
back what it really is is a tool that
allows us to objectively look at what's
happened in our communities what is the
impact of this on the Health Care
Systems and then therefore what should
we be recommending to the public
Colorado's data gave Governor Jared
Polis the green light to ease mandates
for the first time in two years we're
seeing a semblance of normality as
resistance of the virus has reached over
91 percent of coloradans through either
prior infection or full vaccination but
will people really take off their masks
staff at the Good Neighbor restaurant in
Los Angeles say not yet we did have
impressions of coming in today and
everybody being unmasked and it just
being so open but for the safety of
ourselves and everyone else around us we
we're just gonna keep doing what we're
doing until those numbers continue to go
down a little bit
and masks are still required on planes
buses and trains and at the airports the
CDC is expected to review those rules
next month Jeff okay Michael thank you
it is